kanye west you know joe rogan and kanye
west i guess kanye's team whatever
reached out to jeremy before like they
might go on
so kanye's tweeting that he wants to go
on now but the funny thing about this
tweet is he says he's in calabasas
joe i'm in calabasas does he just not i
know
to date with the news but he could fly
to austin in a problem
yeah so he wants to go on that i would
love for
connie to be on there it's just tough
because the great thing about rogan i
think when people like he doesn't
entertain
[ __ ] he does so kanye comes on there
and tries taking over like he did with
trump
remember we went on tr and just which is
impossible to do i think kanye's the
only person in the world who can do it
remember we just took over with trump
and trump let him run
rogan won't let you run he's gonna call
you on your [ __ ] so if
connie's talking about coming up with
his own [ __ ] encyclopedia and
dictionary
rogan's making what the [ __ ] you talking
about yeah so
i would love to see it i'd love to see
it i'm a huge kanye fan
i don't like that he's gotten so
religious and his music gotten shittier
but
i i like what kind let him love god man
let him love it yeah but
make better music you know well his new
stuff god wants to make better
new stuff his snippet has been fun and i
haven't been feeling his shoe game like
the yeezys at all lately
yeah i agree i agree with you on that
but uh his new music is fire
but how [ __ ] big is broken now
big trump tweets to come on kanye west
tweets it comes that's how big
the player said i tweeted go i'll all
[ __ ] wait name a bigger show he'll
reply
maybe with more ratings maybe tucker
carlson
because the debates right now other than
that name a bigger show you're like
you know i'm talking about consistent
consistent for years yeah name a bigger
show than joe rogan
everyone's like are you just saying
because your friend no [ __ ]
bigger than howard he's way bigger than
howard yeah not
rich oh yeah wow
howard b last time you listened to
howard [ __ ] on serious action look at
him coming at me
well you said really howard but it's
like who's listening to siriusxm unless
you're
listening to rogan on itunes spotify i
mean but also at the same time like i
don't listen to a lot of rogan episodes
the one i mean the more recent one that
i've listened [ __ ] man
i know i'm sorry sorry joe sorry joe you
have a team about me i don't [ __ ] with
rogan no i didn't
uh one of the ones that i really like
that he did was uh the one he did with
daryl davis
i thought that was a really great uh
white supremacist the guy that
got uh one two years ago no it was not
it was about a year ago about a year ago
that was over the summer because i was
texting joe about it i think so dude
looks like it changes it up that was not
that was not during covent
can you give me something over before it
was a little bit before covington
six months
a year ago what did you say daryl davis
you said episode 14
january 30th 2020 thank you very much
february march april may
june july august 8 months ago september
october what the [ __ ]
two years ago i said a year ago oh you
did say a year ago
so we're in the middle all right we're
in the middle i respect it you know what
an episode that was the last one you
listened to though a year
or eight months oh no no uh rob funches
i watched that one and uh you watched
kevin hart one
i watched it no i saw his first you
didn't watch oh henry the henry rollins
ones which
of course come on we should get henry
that
we should get henry on here can we do
that i would be worried i bet i could
get him on him man
you know how big i know i'm worried
about it no no no i wouldn't
you didn't be all hard no hey yeah i
mean i know i think he's gonna take
pills
oh yeah no i would do that would be
phenomenal i got to do it i got to
perform with him
i got a picture with him on my ig it's a
great picture dude but i've been
following it
any guess you guys think about you want
to get on let us know
listen yeah when i get off stage at the
lap factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what this from a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son